hemophilia is an x-linked recessive
trait that affects blood clotting if
someone has hemophilia their blood has
trouble clotting if a carrier woman and
a hemophiliac man have a daughter what
is the percent chance that she the
daughter will have hemophilia so if
you're so inspired pause this video and
try to work through this on your own
alright now let's work through this
together and to do this let's think
about the genotypes of both the mother
and the father so let's start with the
mother and since it is an x-linked
recessive trait we're gonna be dealing
with the sex chromosomes so let's just
remind ourselves at the mother because
she's female is going to be xx have two
X chromosomes the father the father is
going to have an X chromosome and a Y
chromosome but now let's think about the
hemophilia
they say it's a carrier woman so a
carrier woman means that one of her two
x chromosomes would have the hemophilia
allele and the other one wouldn't
carrier implies that she doesn't show
the trait she doesn't have hemophilia
but she's carrying one of these x-linked
recessive hemophilia alleles so we could
say that one of her chromosomes one of
her X chromosomes does not have
haemophilia I use capital H for the
dominant allele which you would say is
no chemo philia we tend to use the
capital for the dominant and then the
lowercase H where this would be the X
chromosome that has the hemophilia
allele and I didn't lowercase H because
it is a recessive trait and so this is
hemo hemophilia and now what about the
father
well it's x-linked and the father only
has one x chromosome and they say it's a
hemophiliac man and so that one X
chromosome is going to have the
hemophilia allele and so the reason why
he exhibits hemophilia is that there is
no other X chromosome with the dominant
allele to be dominant over the
hemophilia
allele but now let's cross these two
with a punnett square so the father to
the offspring could contribute the X
chromosome that has the hemophilia
allele
or a y-chromosome and the mother can
contribute the X chromosome that doesn't
have the hemophilia allele or the X
chromosome that does have the hemophilia
allele
and now I'll draw my little punnett
square here so there you go and so what
are the different scenarios
well this top-left scenario would be I
get the X chromosome from the mother
that does not have the hemophilia allele
and I get the X chromosome from the
father that does have the hemophilia
allele this scenario is the X chromosome
from the mother with the hemophilia
allele and the X chromosome from the
father with the hemophilia allele this
scenario is the X chromosome from the
mother with the without the hemophilia
allele so no hemophilia or with the non
hemophilia leo and the y chromosome from
the father and this is the X chromosome
from the mother that has the hemophilia
and the Y chromosome from the father now
what is the percent chance that she that
a daughter would have hemophilia so
which of these scenarios show a daughter
well the daughters are going to be the
XX scenarios so these are the two
scenarios in which they have a daughter
these two because there's a y
chromosomes these would be them having a
son so out of the two scenarios where
they have a daughter one of those
scenarios you have two of the recessive
alleles and so this is a situation where
you have a daughter daughter with
hemophilia emo philia right over here
and so if we know they have a daughter
what is the percent chance that she will
be haemophiliac well one out of two so
there is a 50% chance now what's useful
about this punnett squares you could
answer all sorts of questions you could
say what is the percent chance that they
have a hemophiliac son well one out of
these four scenarios is a hemophiliac
son then you would say there's a 25%
chance that they have a hemophiliac son
similarly there is a 25% chance that
they have a non haemophiliac son if
someone said what is the percent chance
that they have a hemophiliac offspring
well that would be these
two scenarios right over here so two out
of the four scenarios are haemophiliac
offspring so that would be 50% if you
said given that they had a son what is
the percent chance that they don't have
hemophilia well you would say given that
they have a son so that would be those
two scenarios one out of those two
scenarios the son does not have
hemophilia so that would again be a 50%
so anyway hopefully this was useful